long story short I was gonna be very
honest I was kena back home in Mexico so
I ended up living my country so I have
to you know like go out of my country I
came to the United States and so kainalu
was I was having the same life that I
was coming back on back home in Mexico
so I was you know like it doesn't matter
if you come on me okay whatever you have
is it's like inside the heart it was I
was like a zombie like in this world
like doing nothing but you know like
just going after my desires so one day
this is welcome to the Deshawn MIDI your
whole subscribe right now so you can get
the new episode every Friday it's out
deliver directly to you my next guess
we're gonna be time on chapo and the
cartel he was living that kind of
lifestyle void upon void in the heart
depressed empty inside looking for
something on the wrong side but he
finally fought through got through and
he's here on the D show
this is the this is the Salam alaikum
peace be with you my little Salam how do
you say in Spanish peace be with you the
greeting that we do is clap a second do
that's simple huh it's beautiful greedy
yeah now you weren't always saying this
greeting where are you no no no no how
are you from Mexico I'm from Mexico come
I'm I was born and raised in Mexico now
what part of Mexico Monterrey
did they catch Chapo yet I think so yeah
i don't believe that much news but yeah
he's out see that glamorous lifestyle
you got the money at the end it's
finished
adios amigos hasta la vista yeah but
were you living that kind of life style
back then yes I was actually I was doing
the chief of the cartels no no no no you
were but now we did a live feed first
time ever on the Facebook I was thinking
like suicide thoughts and everything
because I didn't want to know anything
about that lie at this life and we just
get a glimpse of why you upset they're
accepted Islam something about you were
kidnapped yes I was about this yeah go
kidnap in the end of 2000 well in 2009 I
got here in 2009 at the end of the of
the year what happened how what is there
some you could talk about like yeah yeah
I think so yeah also goes there
well he was in 2009 it was in 2009 which
is almost six years six years and few
months it was because of you know like
it's happening you don't have to go into
like specific okay yeah so in 2006 or
2009 there was this called drove cartel
so the city where I'm from is in the
north of Mexico so basically the city is
a city where where you know like they do
business that kind of business you know
so everything is started to go like
really really bad and especially you
know like if you are involved in the
streets and things like that so you were
what you were at the wrong company I was
with the wrong
yes I'm trying to achieve the wrong
goals yes and actually I was I was with
my cousin when that happened hamdulillah
nothing happened to me they put you in a
trunk no it was in a van it was in a van
they got us with machine guns in the
head and everything so they took my
cousin out in an order in a North car he
was working you know for the government
so basically it was more because of that
was that stuff and yeah so they talk to
him they today they the cartel was
actually torturing him your cousin yes
wow man you were like it this is some
stuff out of my movies a bad or action
movie or something yeah yeah when I want
to just kind of give a glimpse to see
like how people can pull themselves out
because some people still stuck in that
light hmm they think they watched Tony
Montana yeah I know you watched Tony
Montana right yeah Scarface yes so you
see that and you think okay I'm gonna be
a big shot now round be like Tony but
then you end up in the back of the trunk
somewhere yes and it's like an addiction
you know like one little team brings you
to another thing and then to another
thing and then everything is started to
to go like like I don't know it's like a
combination of arrogance with a little
bit of power you know and then you have
like you're like a famous you among your
friends you know like with the put the
with the friends you know you started to
get like up like a power or or how do
you say like they see you like a
celebrity or something you know so that
started to grow like your ego started to
grow and then it's little by little like
more more and more it's an addictive I
mean it's it's an addiction or exactly
everybody has holes in their hearts my
point of view is how do you feel those
those holes you know do you fill them
with drugs you know with alcohol with
girls so you know being out there making
this money you know so how did you at
what point did you start because
sometimes I mean you're obviously young
you're energetic you have the wrong
examples you don't have a good example
it set up the environment so in in the
of all this how do you take that turn
towards where you're right now yes so
how I say I had to leave my country
basically was more like a self or
ability ssin you know it was more like a
cell rehabilitation I ended up being
hidden in the United States I had the
opportunity to come here so my point was
just to come to the United States learn
English then go back and finish
University but I ended up being he know
hamdulillah and as I said in the
beginning it was very tough because
sometimes we sometimes we think that we
want to move from one place to another
place and the problems will ended up
over there you know in that place but
actually what happened to me is that I
didn't good those problems you know I
was doing bad stuff over there back home
in Mexico then you know in the beginning
when I came to United States it was in
the beginning it was good there you know
like normal because I didn't speak
English because I didn't know anyone
here I don't have any single till this
point I don't have any member of my
family all my family's back home in
Mexico so in the beginning it was good
but then little by little I started to
grow when I started meeting the people
the places I started doing the same
thing that I was doing back over there
you know in the back company you know
and close and then fights tingly that
rolls you know yeah now we're just
dragging the problems just it just keeps
growing and growing and growing yes and
you didn't did you ever at one point did
you ever did you know that you're
conscious
sometimes people they go to extent where
the conscience that's like a signal
that's a blessing from from God from
from Allah that you have this this
inside of you this that goes off and
tell you hold on you shouldn't do that
you know it talks to you were you having
that that guilt that was that was
overtaking you and you were like man I
got to change I got a you know find a
new route yes I always have I always
have the feeling you know I feel I can
consider myself that I was you know
doing good you know with with the family
you know I had that guilt the one that
you're saying but at the same time as I
said in the beginning like everybody has
holes that the problem is how do you
fill those holes I'm coming from a
broken family
and I think my point of view is that
what I didn't have in a family you know
I didn't I was know like you know in a
family where there is like parents
together I was looking for that love or
that that that think outside industry
you know even though I'm coming from a
good family education and everything I
was looking for that you know I was in
the streets you know looking for that
thing so I did have like the guilt to
the point that I was trying to balance
to have the a good life and also the the
the other side you know until the point
that you can never be you can never
handle both whether you whether you have
to whether you decide to be good or do
you decide to be bad you know but you
have to make that decision because in
the middle there is no possible work
good or bad we're gonna take a break and
right back with your incredible story
here the Dean show don't go anywhere
right back
take that simple step that you asked
your maker to guide you that he'll guide
you yes III advise this a lot so for
people researching put your head on the
floor in the in the in the state of
prostration like all the prophets
leaders and ask the creator of the
universe to show you the way to guide
you to the straight path and someone who
sincerely us will guide it
that's it back here on the D show we're
talking about cartel we got chapels
already put away that you know thank God
hum did it love that you didn't continue
going maybe he would have been the next
chapo you had all the money you know
power but then you're hiding in
basements you know the guy went probably
from heaven he was on Forbes magazine
like one of the richest people in the
world but now he's like you know hiding
and put in rat holes and they finally
got him all those things just went to to
an end and hit a big dead end and you
could have been and you got kidnapped
could have been like just at the equates
to nothing did you have peace back then
in your heart we talked about holes in
the heart obviously you didn't there
were empty holes are they feel now yeah
hamdulillah now of course I feel like
totally good you know even some people
that that hate that I that they seem you
know they see man what's going on with
you you know even the face change you
know like back there I think it was more
like hey you know or something even in
the face you know and we mean like you
it was you you seem like that newer
comes out the brightness the people who
are involved in bad thing is dark right
it is it is and it comes out from the
soul that is your heart dark yeah I'm
being in that bad I'm pretty sure the
the people that are watching of they
they know what I'm talking about because
if you are in that path you can notice
if you can recognize what's going on
when you you know something you see when
you're doing all the most evil things
that just comes out yes and something
you say like in Spanish week I was
saying dinero fossil fossil viene
facility ba yes like easy money is it
comes easy go ya know
you know no blessing no no no no
blessing Wow
so tell us more like were you ever for
someone who's on that other side
did you ever did the question ever come
up like what's the purpose of life why
am I here in this world did you ever
think about those things yeah all the
time all the time and I was I was I was
not happy you can be happy but it's a
short time you can be happy for maybe
one day a couple hours but then at the
end of the day you and they're all being
the same person you know like alone you
know and then that's what you do you go
back to to what you do you know about to
the alcohol would you go back you know
to the drugs or whatever because you're
trying to get the chasing after
something that is just for a very short
period of time
now don't a lot of these drug dealers
cartel they're actually many of them are
very religious people I mean not
technically in a sense like they're in
church of each Saturday but you'll see
like right now I don't think she will
ever get out dope from a bit you may not
have heard of her but recently Santa
Muerte began making international
headlines amid reports of ritual human
sacrifice just south of the US border in
Mexico a lot of cartel members in Mexico
account among the ranks of her devotees
is nothing new to those who battle drug
lords and traffickers the candles are
often used to set up shrines that's the
sound of a man being tortured inside the
home where the man was tortured is this
shrine descent a morte just showed a
clip you know they're doing the trick
you know the the cross many of them
there's the saint of death
have you heard sent that was it more
time yeah yeah actually it was sometime
one of them yeah what what's good what's
all this about yeah I mean that's that's
I mean I think when you're not in the
right guidance you ended up having your
your you know like having your idols who
or whatever you know actually the people
that I used to hang out they used to
believe in Santa more thing you know
like we used to have even like that's
good that you mentioned that we used to
having one of my body
like a big big Santa Muerte over there
yes popular over there huh yeah what's
that literally means that means the
saint of death is the saint up there but
basically you you ask for for favors you
know you ask for favors and basically if
you are involved in bad stuff you know
you ask for protection you know to not
take take you you know because you know
that being in that path you are risk you
know all the time you you gotta watch
your back and then you have to know that
your life can be gone in one second you
know should you ask for protection you
know to the to the ground you know so
you have a lot of that in Mexico Saint
to worship saint of death all these
different idols i mean it's everywhere
you know like there is even a
drug-dealer disco his name is usman
birthday you know like there is people
who worship kazoos mal birthday who's my
bread it was mal better he's not what is
he he was I think he was like a drug
dealer back in the 70s or or even before
nothing we're showing him yeah the
people have their their like their stuff
over there and they have like a altars
they put candy they put like about like
bottles of tequila candles and then
fruits and then all these stuff you know
like and what and now I mean because
obviously there's there's the yearning
inside to wanna worship and if you're
not worshiping the Creator you're
worshiping the creation now how at the
end what's the difference with Islam now
who are you directing this worship to
have newly learn now now is like a
straight to the one that created us you
know that it's a creator and that is the
creation you know there is just one
creator everything else is creation you
know whatever you want to follow whether
if whether if you are people you are
worshiping the money if you have the
money in your heart you ended up
worshiping the money you know if you are
doing pool putting yourself into these
stops it tough situation you know you
ended up worshipping this stuff you know
but now is like a straight to the
creator you know and I should have
Spanish the rock dial up straight to the
to the one who created I commend the
Gandhi
Stasi directamente condos come to carry
on or that comes natural when you come
on yes that's powerful yeah I just
learned English a four years ago
why are you doing good my brother thank
you so much yeah well you did learning
some some Arabic phrases also yeah I'm
studying now you come a long way
masha'Allah this is really this is
really great coming from where you were
you know aspiring to come on
did you tell most people want to be like
Chapel don't mask in there or who's the
next guy one of these guys you idolize
because we're creatures of imitation so
you're looking at these guys and you're
like I want to be like him yeah some
things is just like I I just honestly
honestly I don't understand you know
some things I can feel you know that I
see you know I'm running away from that
path you know running away from that
path and I can see some things you know
like people going back the path that I
was you know he's not something fun it's
not cool you know people think that is
cool because of these movies all these
people talking about that stuff like a
celebrity like like if he's something
good you know but this is not this is
nothing that I would recommend not even
to my worst enemy is is like darkness
you know and the last one immortality
speeded arnis and put them on the leg
and at the same time he can take people
from the light and put them in the
darkness you know and I can tell because
I was already in the darkness you know I
already know you know maybe the the
Hellfire is after that but you can even
feel like the hot stuff you know like
things that you watch is just like no
not recommendable for for anyone you
know it's like a lot of Tears you can
lose your family you know I wipe at one
point that was my family you know I lost
my friends I even you know lost my
country you know that you can be like
with nothing you know no money
wow we're gonna take a break and then
we're gonna talk about more of what you
found now thank you filled here on the
Dean show don't go anywhere don't forget
if you haven't subscribed right now back
here on the Dean so very exciting
episode my brother here you were
then all of the horrible things darkside
you on the dark side of life with voids
in your heart how does the heart feel
now this on the line now now I feel I
feel like sometimes people don't
understand again is like I mean I know
they're like I can see things in another
dimension you know I can see the beauty
you know even the people that I'm around
you know it's just something beautiful
you know that that that's something just
don't understand you know it's like like
another dimension you know you can see
the beauty of these life you know back
in the day if it was just like a zombie
come on son am below do you know like a
zombie you know like we're not workers
you know just walking around but my
purpose ya know what's the difference
for it for our brothers and sisters in
humanity like some people get this this
feeling now they turn to let's say
worshipping Jesus who we love you know
you can't be a Muslim unless you love me
or Jesus you actually you love sharing
now you know Dawa you love communicating
and you know because we care we share
what do you tell people who now they
worship this mighty messenger that the
crater sent yes I mean there are there
are many things that are there that they
can deviate that when they start
worshipping you know again I'm from
Mexican you know Catholic background you
know and you go back to - I go back to
Mexico you know and there's many sayings
you know many things for for many things
you know but when people start
worshipping that you know they are
actually forgiving about the Creator you
know the Creator you know like they're
worshiping like the creation you know or
stones or you know like a status or
pictures or whatever you know there's
something above above that you know
sometimes our internet can not even
understand you know but it is there you
know so there are many deviations but
the one that is worthy of worship is the
one who created everything the owner of
the Day of Judgment
that's deep I mean that's really
profound only worshiping the one who's
worthy of worship and that's the one who
created everything
sadly the one who wasn't in anybody's
womb didn't no one gave birth to him
didn't walk to earth he is all
knowledgeable on knowing and that's the
same one that Jesus peace be upon him
worship that's the Creator you're
worshiping exactly yea there are there
are many messengers there are many
prophets who came to the earth who were
walking here in their with the message
you know some of them they got the
revelation you know yes we followed
their teaches their revelations but we
don't worship them when we Muslims
post-trade the face in the ground or we
bound we bound to the Creator no - no -
another person not even to Prophet
Muhammad yeah how do you say that in
Spanish would you just say Prophet
Muhammad kill a possibility for that we
when we put our head to the ground we
only worship the Creator see cuando
cuando la la la frente en el suelo
cuando NOS entry Nommos cuando se more
referencia es solamente para el creed or
no lo samos para nada mas no lo se
mondesi Kiera para un Profeta on men
Sahara Nisa quiere para nuestro Profeta
ultima Mensa hero chaser Prophet
Mohammed passive indigenous an con el
nosotros no loss in camos al no sin
comisarios wow that's deep tell us have
you had some good interaction with other
Latinos now that you are one who's
chosen this way of life you have peace
many people they might be going in that
direction that you are in and you get a
chance to speak to them are they
receptive to the to the message yeah
yeah I think I think Latinas are very
close to to embrace his land you know
and some things they don't even know you
know but when you talk to them when you
ask them you know even the teachings you
know it's very similar the way they live
and the way that we Muslim Lee you know
like real Islam you know and you know
even the way that they think sometimes
is like oh yes I believe in God you know
do you believe that Jesus is God no no
no no some things they say no no I don't
believe in the church I don't believe in
these I just believe in God you know
sometimes is stood up to that point you
know where they they believing in God so
when you ask them you know or when you
try to talk to them about Islam is that
you know is like I'm Catholic or I'm
Christian but
just for tradition you know this is how
I grew up you know when you unwrap the
package when you explain them what is
Islam
you know what Muslim we believe you know
then is when they start understanding
then is when the thoughts and the
actions start matching you know but
there are very very receptive
you know Latino we are very receptive to
understand that's why I mean hamdulillah
Islam is the fastest growing religion
and among the people that are embracing
Islam are the Latinos you know the
Latinos usually sisters are embracing
Islam we can we can see in the in the
communities you know a lot of women now
also women faster than men there's that
misconception that Islam oppresses
remember why're they come into Islam if
it oppresses them really you know doing
opposite of what the media saying
exactly exactly yeah come to learn now
now I'm able to to be part of this
nonprofit organization is called Islam
in Spanish I'm the one over there in the
chapter over there you know Dallas
Dallas for war area hamdulillah we are
doing great things over there
Islam expand Islam in Spanish before we
go tell us for for the younger the old
woman or man and they might be preparing
to go to the nightclub this weekend
this guy he's trying to you know lift a
lot of weight so he can you know be mr.
mafioso he's trying to live that life he
wants to get the kilos you know make the
birth though and dates for some reason
they turn it into the Dean show what
would you tell him cuando te toka I'm
gonna keep this cuando no I'm get the
pongas that's the sane in Spanish that
we that we have whenever needs you
return even if you move out it's gonna
be your turn but whenever it is not your
turn even if you put in the situation it
is not gonna be your turn you know so
just just to use a district sample of
many people that were brought to light
and you know like many people in the Rob
like like people that I knew you know
they got killed you know people like
like really really really bad so you
know in dropping yell or kill or
kidnapping them their moms you know to
make them go go with
with them you know so there is there is
a darkness over there there is a
darkness and you know it's it's just
something that that you don't need to
you don't need to you need to taste you
know there is people that we were
already in that pad you know just like
we are telling you that if we already
passed through that and alhamdulillah we
are able to go out just just say Chris
an example you know don't don't don't
try yourself because you can never go
out you can enter up in pretty soon you
can ended up cute or your family killed
or or doing something you know doing
something stupid
we're gonna go in at last ten seconds
say that you know when someone
acknowledges that there is a purpose in
life and who does to tell me the one who
created life and then you make that
Proclamation that shadow allah wa ashadu
anna muhammadan abduhu rasul can you say
it in spanish to show how easy it is and
then translate it go ahead see potassium
but it's a muscle man but a ceremony
mucho this is like gente piensa que is
commonly - al Oh al was he different to
me a Muslim sometimes there is people
that think that is a ritual or you know
something stuff but para ser muscle man
is not a mass it's not a mass con con el
corazon lo que una teeny generally could
assume when they're doing su Boca case
at the steve-o can you exist in a van in
nadie Khanderao cerrado except Oh Dios
yet tasty whoa okay Mohammed a saloon
two moments a hero one dune was septic a
mohammed sallu tomb in Sahara automatic
Ament a stout acept ando 200 lumens a
hero's and 3 horas Moy says no his shoes
whenever somebody you know said some
hummus peace be upon him as the
messenger automatically he's accepting
all the messenger that's what basically
what I'm saying in Spanish is just to
acknowledge básicamente to testify car
testify car que nosotros no Liron demos
cuando se na da da da da Mo's inada
Nino's des vamos kannada a sceptic on
Dios has become Hamilton that's it
worship the Creator not the creation
it's no saint of death no messenger
nobody in the middle just your Creator
thank you so much for your analysis
thank you for tuning in that was really
exciting and a very touching story and
you got to learn some Spanish also so
for our Latino brothers in humanity the
message got delivered to you look into
it you can see that there's hope for
everybody look there's gonna come a time
when we all died then it's too late
like when the test is over it rings it's
finished so when the rattle of death
comes and it approaches you up here it's
coming out it's ready the the soul is
ready to come out that is too late but
until then you have time now you can
either waste that time and you're still
empty inside your conscious is calling
your heart is calling for something more
like it you can identify like what
happened to our special guest of this
week that was the turning point his life
when he when he put his head down and he
asked the crater alone for guidance and
and that's something that is just so
simple but yet to many think it's some
kind of like confusing riddle but it's
it's so simple that it's right in front
of you do what he did and want many who
have found purpose and peace asked the
one who created you directly to guide
you start with that and then you will
start to see the good that will come
from that request that you've made but
you'll see the negative things darkness
upon darkness going from this club
trying to imitate chapo trying to be
like this gangster trying to live gain
this kind of lifestyle Wall Street
lifestyle trying to be the big multi
millionaire billionaire with this car
that car now you at UFC champion you've
got the ladies and the honeys or the let
the women out there now you've got a
closet full of all sorts of genes and
fashion is just your number one priority
in life but your bust inside your
bankrupt inside you are empty in your
heart like he was but now what was the
whole point you watch the show now you
can see how you can get out of that
empty space out from that darkness into
the light by doing
something simple just like hit he did
and God willing you can have that gift
that's priceless that money can't buy
and that's from that mercy of the one
who created you but you got to ask for
it and do it before the time runs out
because death is a reality it will come
and all of this play and amusement is
just distracting us get with it get
right with the one who created you with
God Almighty with the law and everything
will start to fall in place subscribe
again if you haven't subscribed right
now we'll see you next time until then
peace be with you
don't forget as I asked you to do
already if you have it subscribed right
now